thank you for coming
my name is india huang i'm a phd
candidate at east asian
language cultures columbia university
i'm primarily working on
modern content with china especially
social and political history
so on behalf of my myself and my fellow
panelists i want to thank
uh denise stephanie and host cis teams
for providing this wonderful opportunity
for us
to share our research so without further
ado
i'd like to introduce our first speaker
galvin hiding so gavin is also a phd
candidate at columbia university
elac he works primarily on the the
tourist sector in in mouse china
good morning thank you thank you yunji
thank you denise and stephanie
i'm just going to share my screen so
workers in china's service sector during
the mao era
perform their jobs under the guidance of
campaigns that attempted to define
the political and economic nature of
service labor
but service workers or yen
working in hotels restaurants and
transportation facilities that served
overseas chinese
hong kong and macau compatriots and
other foreign tourists
found themselves in a precarious
position
not only were they working in an
industry outside primary production
they were serving people who were not
necessarily considered
the people for these foolish
or service was a matter of heightened
sensitivity
they were portrayed as the face of the
new society and were urged to perform
their work accordingly
as ful yen on the guangzhou shanzhan
railway put it
when we do our work well it reflects
well on the party
when we do our work poorly it damages
the prestige of the party
this political element of fool was cited
in model worker narratives
as something that gave this
non-productive service work meaning
um yet striving for attentive service
and satisfying the demands of foreign
guests were not always easy to reconcile
with political rhetoric that emphasized
serving
the people in a hierarchy of labor that
privileged
agricultural and industrial production
over the course of the 1970s foo
and its relationship to tourism china's
economy
and the prestige of the socialist nation
changed in many ways
central to this was a redefinition of
the people
that foolien would be called to serve
as the relationship of the chinese state
with the broader world transformed
fujian served new types of guests and
found themselves navigating
new conceptions of the proper way to
serve them
worker education campaigns continue to
emphasize the importance of
proper service attitude but the meaning
of tourism service changed over the
course of the decade
as it was interpreted first through the
lens of revolutionary diplomacy
and then in terms of the modernization
of the chinese state
in the early 1970s fujian at panji
restaurant in guangzhou
discussed how prior to the cultural
revolution
they pursued feudalist capitalist and
revisionist service
to a small class of bourgeoisie with the
start of the cultural revolution however
they said they abandoned the
counter-revolutionary line
of putting profit in command and
targeting both refined
and popular taste henceforth
they pledged to serve dishes and deem
some for the masses
other restaurants with a long
pre-revolutionary history pledged to do
the same
in 1969 the revolutionary committee of
the guangzhou restaurant
in a report on its struggle to answer
the fundamental question of service for
whom
likewise repudiated the principle of
targeting
both refined and popular taste
the committee asserted that the answer
to the question of service for whom
was service to the proletariat and the
restaurant's perpetuation
of its pre-revolutionary legacy of
refined cuisine
was revisionism in the past they said
the line in the restaurant between
refined and popular
had been quite clear when referring to
refined
and popular we considered the exploiting
class refined
and considered the working people
popular
but now that sort of bourjois rubbish
has been thoroughly eradicated
but 1971 saw two seemingly unrelated
but in fact closely connected
announcements from china's highest
leadership
that brought about a shift in the
conceptualization of tourism service
labor
and its relationship to refined and
popular taste
in july 1971 mao authorized state
tourism authorities
to increase the number of foreign
tourists allowed into china
and to permit the entry of not just
political leftists
and foreign friends but self-financed
rightists as well
a month later chairman mao's
revolutionary diplomatic line
was publicly articulated in the people's
daily
the revolutionary diplomatic line was
the heading given to a broad policy
of internationalist solidarity against
imperialism
as well as solidarity with workers and
oppressed people living within
capitalist
and imperialist nations coming just
weeks before the prc's admission to the
u.n
the announcement of this policy has been
described as part of a modern
modernization or moderation of earlier
policies
marking a consolidation of power in the
foreign ministry under joe and lie
yet while this policy seems little more
than a restatement of by then
long-standing pronouncements
of afro-asian solidarity it differs
in at least one important respect the
revolutionary diplomatic line
provided an ideological framework to
justify china's increasing engagement
with nations of the capitalist world
well just a few years earlier the
people's daily criticized the
revisionism
apparent in soviet overtures toward
western tourists
the revolutionary diplomatic line
separated
the people from the nation opening up
space to serve western tourists
while continuing to publicly repudiate
the neocolonial policies of their
governments
for china's tourism industry this meant
a focus on new types of customers
and new ways of conceptualizing labor
in december 1971 the revolutionary
committee of panshi restaurant
annunciated the role of fujian in the
revolutionary diplomatic line
the committee reported that fujim must
take the lead in serving foreign guests
must publicize mao zedong thought and be
careful in carrying out their full work
they must understand the ways of life of
foreign guests and adjust their services
to suit foreign guests habits and
customs
while they continue to speak with
contempt for targeting both refined and
popular taste
this was belied by the attention paid to
skill variety
and refinement when these could be
linked to the role of fujian
in revolutionary diplomacy
when a group of japanese guests asked
the restaurant to prepare new varieties
of dim sum
every day for 30 days the chefs said
they considered this work
for the honor of the fatherland and to
win glory for chairman mao
their completion of this culinary
challenge they said
illustrated the material abundance of
socialist china
these varieties of diem sum they said
exquisitely crafted
gave the guests a deep impression and
showed how the chefs
and fool yen wholeheartedly served
chairman mao's revolutionary diplomatic
line
chefs from the overseas chinese hotel in
shanghai similarly rethought notions
such as targeting refined
and popular taste and emphasis on the
importance of skilled labor
when they spoke with the pride of the
compliments they received from guests on
their cooking
this they said was studying professional
skill
for the sake of revolution in organizing
a study group
to analyze customers tastes and develop
new dishes
they said they came to see more clearly
the political meaning of cooking
in the service of chairman mao's
revolutionary diplomatic
line but their position at the vanguard
of the revolutionary diplomatic line
forced service workers to confront a
number of difficult issues
as a report from the shanghai mansions
hotel noted
fulien needed to draw clear lines
between popularization
and simplification polite eagerness
and obsequiousness actively serving
foreign guests and fawning over them
learning skills for the sake of
revolution
and placing skill above all else
national dignity and arrogant great
nation chauvinism
being mindful of poison grace and
pursuing a bourgeois manner of dress
and careful management of the purchase
and sale of goods
versus a capitalist emphasis on material
incentives
and profit above all else
it's evident that the lines between
these concepts were not entirely clear
to fool yen at the time just as the
lines between many of them
remain unclear in tourism and other
service industries in china's
post-socialist world today
not long after the death of mao in 1976
fool came to be linked to the four
modernizations
the four modernizations development of
agriculture
industry science and technology and
national defense
originated in a report of joe and lie to
the national people's congress in 1975
and were written into the constitution
in 1978
the skills necessary for football work
in service of the four modernizations
increasingly resembled the appeal to
both refined and popular taste
described decried in the recent past
fulien learn more types of cuisine the
customs and tastes of guests from a
greater variety of nations
and more exacting standards of table
settings and etiquette
hotel and restaurant workers studied new
texts
like professional knowledge for service
workers
shifting the focus of worker campaigns
from the close of the 70s
and into the 80s from mere valorization
of full labor
to professionalization of it
acknowledging the importance of
increased professionalization
a fool will work bao guangcheng a xinhua
news reporter writing the people's daily
in 1979
cited projections that over the next
decade more than 85 percent
of new employment would be in light
industry handicraft and service related
work
referring to the steel works in the
baoshan district of shanghai
that took seven years to build and
employed 30 000 workers
bowel noted the impossibility of heavy
industry alone
supplying the jobs necessary for china's
rapidly expanding workforce
val said that with the workforce
projected to grow by 3 million workers a
year
from 1980 to 1985. if heavy industry
were the sole source of new employment
the nation would have to build a hundred
baoshon steelworks each year
to meet the demands of the labor market
for this reason
the service light industry and
handicraft sectors
were seen as the main path to employment
in the coming years
bow acknowledged that many still adhere
to what he termed
the traditional outlook in society of
looking down
upon the service industry yeah while
pointing out that many people did not
consider a full work
to be an honorable occupation serving
the people
bow differed from writers in previous
years who proposed ideological campaigns
as the means to improve service worker
morale and instead cited only the
influence of low wages
and lack of social welfare benefits on
the morale of service workers
tourism and tourism-related foo were
still occasionally linked to the
revolutionary diplomatic line
as late as 1979 but the objectives of
tourism and food
had clearly expanded along with the
growing prominence of the four
modernizations in public discourse
food work was by this time connected to
a tourism industry
that was not merely ancillary to
political goals but whose development
was was a goal in and of itself as an
integral part of the for modernizations
urging fujian to abandon the notion that
full work was menial
instructional text for them linked full
both to national development goals
and to broader definitions of the
concept of serving the people
asserting that service to overseas
chinese
hong kong and macau compatriots and
foreign guests
is necessary for the nation's foreign
policy commercial intercourse
international exchange and development
of tourism industry
all of which are in service socialist
construction
and service to the people
from the 12th party congress in 1982 the
four modernizations
evolved to new forms of political and
economic planning
in respect of the tourism industry vice
premier juan lee
set forth the principle of friendship
first with economic benefits
as one state tourism industry researcher
interpreted it
friendship first with economic benefits
reflected not the primacy
of one of these aspects of tourism over
the other but the intrinsic
unified relationship of the political
and the economic
tourism he said was an activity with
economic attributes
but it also carried political meaning in
its role and acquisition of advanced
technology
and management experience from abroad
and in its promotion
of understanding and friendship between
the people of china
and the peoples of the world as the
director of the shanghai tourism
training school put it in 1983
the goal set out in the tourism policy
of friendship first with economic
benefits
was to reap bumper harvest in both
politics and economics
this was an acknowledgment he said that
in the past it was wrong to settle
accounts
in political terms alone without
considering economics but to pursue
economic benefits alone
and ignore politics to ignore the
political mission of china's tourism
industry
would harm the reputation of china's
tourism and the reputation of the nation
itself yet the roots of these practical
and discursive shifts came much earlier
and the announcement of chairman mao's
revolutionary diplomatic line
in 1971 set the stage for the commercial
revolution
that would be carried out in china's
tourism service industry
over the course of the 1970s and beyond
thank you
thank you gavin so our second speaker
peter e hammerton is a system professor
at tunica college ireland he primarily
he primarily works on transnational
networks in between mainland china hong
kong us
i think his first book has just come out
congratulations
uh peter and he's currently working on
his new project on origins of business
schools in china
so peter please i'll go ahead and share
my screen
i'd like to thank yandia for
spearheading this panel all my fellow
panelists for sharing their
their excellent papers and both denise
ho and the
l council on east asian studies for
sponsoring this virtual panel with
professional development opportunities
curtailed right now i really thank you
for your leadership and generosity
in 1991 nine universities inaugurated
china's first
permanent mba programs by 2006 there
would be 100 such programs
in the prc and 236
by 2015. on one level this explosive
growth
testifies to a long history of chinese
engagement
with the discourse of scientific
management over the 20th century
which is the subject of my new book
project
and this engagement took root in the
early republican era through
transnational circulations of knowledge
but had been derailed amid the great
leap forward
viewed in this light the revival of
management education
represented a return to modernizing and
developmentalist practices
from before the mile era on another
level though
mba programs seem to pose a paradox
although prc officials have long
considered education to be a politically
sensitive
area these programs were heavily based
on u.s models
and often established in partnership
with american universities
and even with funding from elite
us-educated overseas chinese
in this slide the revival of management
education looked a lot like state's
state-sanctioned foreign and capitalist
influence
many scholars have examined the role of
foreign expertise in the reform era
and the evolution of grassroots
management practices in factories and
firms
but historians have not really examined
the simultaneous revival of management
education
as a key component of china's economic
reforms
and so this paper attempts to fill that
gap and contribute to both scholarship
on the reform era
and sino-us relations so first i will
discuss several initiatives
to revive management education in the
early 1980s
and the entwined discourse of management
as a science
and then i will discuss the
transformation of management education
at qinghua and fudan
over the late 1980s and 1990s which had
a huge impact
on all subsequent chinese mba programs
so in the cultural revolution's wake
a consistent theme and logic among the
diverse reformers
was refocusing the prc's industrial
management practices
around new ideals of efficiency and
science
as a result while scholars have studied
the origins and debate of macroeconomic
policy shifts
a more mundane but vital aspect of this
new era
was simply retraining ordinary managers
in both the party
and throughout state-owned enterprises
in more professional notions of
management
as a result there was a spate of ensuing
initiatives in the early 1980s in
government and in industry to research
management science
and retrain ordinary cameras and
managers in its ways
can't really go into it very many but
one that is illustrative
uh was launched by the first ministry of
machine building or egypt
and the ichibu was one of the single
largest pieces in the prc civilian
industrial sector then
and also ran its own system of colleges
as such
the egypt had a vast and really unwieldy
portfolio of responsibilities
that could use more efficient and better
management
as such with political backing for
boeipo and liaochanger
in the fall of 1978 the ichibu hired a
young
mit doctoral student who was studying on
exchange in beijing
named joseph badat to launch a program
in systems engineering
fluent in mandarin and versed in the
political rhetoric bad it was able to
tour the egypt's factories
uses networks to purchase materials and
hire faculty and launch this program at
the shanghai institute of mechanical
engineering
in early 1979 and while termed systems
engineering
in bat its own words it was quote an mba
program in all but name
lacking only for instruction in finance
another set of management science
initiatives emanated from the new
chinese academy of social sciences and
its institute of industrial economics
these included research projects a
postgraduate program
and even a national distance learning
course known as the periodical
university the institute of industrial
economics
also formed the chinese association of
industrial enterprise
management education in 1979
which sponsored the writing and
publication of the first management
textbook
published since the cultural revolution
written between march 1979 and august
1980 by 27 economists and scholars of
management
management the textbook industrial
enterprise management is really
fascinating on a number of levels
as well as a statement about the revival
of these disciplines
this textbook also sought to reconcile
two key concepts
chinese socialism and scientific
management
in very simple and direct language the
text repeatedly asserted
that future state-owned enterprise
managers must understand quote that
enterprise management is a science
and that the improvement of china's
management service was quote a necessary
condition
for socialist modernization
simultaneously the texts studiously
avoided bourgeois terms
such as profit and even marshaled marx
himself to declare that large-scale
production
would quote inevitably produce
supervisory labor
and command labor in chapter one in
particular does really heavy ideological
lifting to establish the crucial
theoretical basis
for the prc to borrow safely from
capitalist management practices
in the 1950s soviet and prc management
texts always stressed
that economics was subordinate to party
leadership which is
an obviously unscientific precept now
chapter one put forth an innovative
theory of management's
dual nature or archonxing
[Music]
in this theory which is visualized here
in this amazing
chart that i'm happy to discuss further
in the q a
the writing group argued that capitalist
and social systems social systems of
management
had but one common nature or gong xing
when it came to honing ever more
efficient forces of production
based on facts experience and reason
thus in this realm which is on the left
side of this chart
chinese management could learn from
capitalist management to boost
productivity
drive innovation and deliver greater
material rewards
yet when it came to the social relations
of production on the right of the chart
capitalist and socialist systems of
management had distinct
individual natures are gushing that must
be safeguarded
here there would be no borrowing and
this separation would ensure
that learning from capitalist methods
did not become exploitation
in particular the texts stressed the
maintenance of state ownership as
crucial insurance
to preserve the correct social relations
of production
this creative justification for
injecting capitalist management
into chinese socialism encapsulates the
intellectual work that was being done by
reformists
particularly these academics in the
early 1980s it repeatedly addressed the
cultural revolution head-on
acknowledging that quote extreme leftism
in enterprise management
had caused quote serious harm to the
development of management science in our
country
in turn the text insisted that now there
would be no conflict
between scientific management and party
policies
since in quote normal times party
policies and state planning
always appeared to objective laws
and so this isn't clear the textbook is
really trying to reinvigorate management
science as an intellectual bulwark
against any return to the economic
fantasies of the mao era
simultaneously the dual nature theory
seemed to safely reassure everyone that
there would be no changes to the
ownership of state firms
and so in short the inevitable
conclusion of the textbook was not just
that scientific management and chinese
socialism were compatible
but rather that they were an essential
pairing to achieve the four
modernizations
and thus the textbook makes very
explicit and concrete and the precise
intellectual work
necessary to reconcile socialist
ideologies
and increasingly capitalist practices
so with the time remaining i want to
briefly highlight how these kinds of
initial efforts to revive management
education on scientific grounds
evolved toward american style mba
programs in the 1990s
the first formal mba program was
established in 1984
at the dalian university of technology
in partnership with suny
but this program did not last very long
and unfortunately i don't yet know why
because that research has been derailed
by the pandemic
future premier jurong ji was a driving
force though
in establishing qingha's school of
economics and management
also in 1984 and he spoke often
throughout the late 1980s of the urgent
need to improve china's management
standards through retraining
yet as jew's political career
accelerated the actual administration of
chiang mai sem largely fell to his
colleague
jiao chun jun in 1986 chima employed
zhao as the deputy dean
and like zhu jaw was an electrical
engineer by training who had now pivoted
towards systems engineering
emphasizing again the scientific
aspirations
behind the revival of management yet in
reality management education at every
major prc university remained small
under-resourced and very intellectually
constrained
at both chiang mai and fudan there was
little to no dedicated space
a faculty of primarily mathematicians
and engineers
and teeth teaching methods that
consisted primarily of three-hour
lectures
and so as a result by the late 1980s
both jurong-ji
and fudan's jung chalian were
increasingly convinced of the need for
an intellectual
international partnership particularly
with top us business schools
as seen through balit's program mit had
long been engaged in such endeavors in
the region
and was very interested in expanding uh
and was doing so throughout the late
1980s and early 1990s
and by 1994 sloane's leaders had decided
that chilhot and fudan were the most
promising institutions in the prc for a
potential partnership
and dispatched a team under associate
dean allen white
to investigate the two schools to try to
decide between them
and even though there were skeptics uh
on both sides
uh the enthusiastic support of scholars
such as physicist and mit graduate
shiashita
purportedly helped convince sloan to
actually partner with both institutions
and the three schools signed a
memorandum of understanding
in june 1995.
and for fuden and chinhua the primary
goals of the mit china
management education project were quote
faculty development
and the development of cutting-edge
curricula for mba students
who will operate internationally this
cutting-edge
curricula is particularly important in
marking the
transition away from overly quantitative
uh
and scientific approaches and toward
once unthinkable courses in things such
as communications
marketing leadership and other subjects
and this is primarily mapping on to
china's drive towards the socialist
market economy and perhaps the
justifications of things like the dual
nature theory
allowed them uh the leaders of the three
schools
to put the political differences between
them aside
so the memorandum of understanding makes
no mention of any particular political
conflicts
except noting a few areas that we put
off limits
such as industrial relations
this ability to ignore politics was also
enabled by where the funding came from
primarily from elite mit alumni in hong
kong
a particular link with with the book
that just came out
chinese american executive shirley young
had warned mit against accepting any
funds
from the chinese government and instead
alan white had recruited
tycoons such as these four to bankroll
this program
these u.s educated hong kong elites also
joined this project's advisory board
and pushed the mit china project to
focus on sponsoring trans-pacific
educational circulations from the fall
of 1996
fudan and ching-hwa's deans began
dispatching junior scholars
to cambridge for a term or a year as
international faculty fellows
and these sponsored exchanges allow
chinese professors to improve their
english
study mba methodologies and prepare to
teach
many of the exact same materials in
their own classrooms
since i'm running out of time i will
wrap up by highlighting just two
aspects of the ensuing knowledge
circulations here
first this opportunity was essentially
mandatory
for chinese faculty and often included
wholesale career change
for example jun chen xiao jun made a
huge disciplinary shift
from applied mathematics to managerial
communications
she commented quote i was in my second
year of teaching statistics
when dean zhao asked me to learn to
teach managerial
communications i wondered about taking
on a subject so far from my original
field
he said that no one at chiang hua knew
what a course in communication
should be but that mit sloan placed
great importance on it
the course needed to be taught in
english and he thought i could do this
if i observed how it was taught at mit
sloan
in ants in essence chen's fluent english
determined jiao's decision to reroute
her entire career
after her time at mit in fall 1997
chen not only returned to teach
managerial communications from the same
textbook
but also became a national leader in
developing this field
across chinese universities indeed
second
and finally the knowledge produced by
the mit partnership was rapidly
disseminated
throughout all chinese mba programs in
fall 1994
the state council in the ministry of
education approved the formation of the
national mba
education supervisory committee with
dean zhao as its first chair
and the participants basically the
leaders of this were worried that the
rapid expansion of mba
programs in china would undermine their
quality
and thus the new national committee
created a mandatory core
mba curriculum in which roughly half
the nationally mandated or recommended
core courses
aligned closely with or are virtually
identical
to the mit sloan courses and so for
example in 2005
the committee began to require all mba
programs
to teach managerial communications june
shen then compiled
the recommended course outline book and
to this day teaches an annual seminar to
train other scholars
in the relevant case studies another
example i won't go into but can talk
about is
is the course and textbook data models
and decisions
and so to wrap up this paper and
presentation map out a two-part
transition
in chinese management education and
ideologies
over the 1980s and 1990s first away from
cultural revolution rhetoric
and towards scientific ideals and then
toward american modeled mba programs
through partnership with mit these
shifts highlight that senior leaders
were thinking very actively about
management education
as part of the economic reforms and that
transnational networks and actors
had real influence in shaping the
content and quality
of chinese higher education at least in
this realm
perhaps most importantly focusing on
management education
helps to illuminate and make more emic
sense of the intellectual work behind
the reform era's blending
of socialist ideologies and capitalist
practices
thank you
thank you peter so our third speaker is
adam frost um
adam is a phd candidating history
department harvard university
he works primarily on entrepreneurship
in southeast china adam please
hello hello well great talks um yeah so
in my talk i'm going to be doing
something
a little different and i am going to be
showing how i study
this period from you know a more kind of
bottom-up perspective
so my research has been motivated by
what i see as the central puzzle
of modern chinese economic development
namely how is it that after three
decades
of violently suppressing capitalism the
chinese
state was able to transform its economy
uh virtually overnight into this engine
and dynamic
and sustained growth i mean according to
the prevailing view
of chinese development prior to reform
and opening up the chinese state
presided over
a quote-unquote cellular economy with
highly atomized production
and exchange society was divided up into
these
self-reliant administrative units like
the commune the city
labor markets were abolished and the
state erected
all kinds of barriers to mobility and
exchange such as the household
registration system
and as the china sociologist marty
wright ver
very recently put it in terms of
the movement of people goods and
services china in 1978
at the beginning of reform and opening
up was a less integrated economy than in
1949
but here's the problem as i see it if
the chinese socialist economy were truly
atomized as late as 1978 whence came the
sudden and powerful entrepreneurial
impulse
so in my dissertation and in this paper
in particular i develop and analyze
original data sets to argue that
socialist china was not in fact void of
entrepreneurial activity
i show that beneath the veneer of the
formal socialist economy there is this
dynamic
realm of economic activity where
entrepreneurs are
actively filling in holes uh profiting
from inefficiencies in the planned
economy
and more generally just making things
work
and specifically i use new empirical
evidence that i
myself created or put assembled to
advance the following three
propositions i argue that the china
chinese social state was never that
successful
in suppressing private entrepreneurial
activity that
entrepreneurship under chinese socialism
was both
greater in scale and scope than previous
scholarship would lead us to believe
and that the central and local
governments were not
unified in their efforts to enforce
formal socialist institutions and
suppress private
activity um
sorry oh sorry here um so the reason why
existing scholarship has you know sort
of gotten mischaracterized
socialist china i think has to do with
the over-reliance on high-level policy
documents
and official statistics i mean these
sources at best suffer from extreme
biases and at worst are
really political fictions that are meant
to advance state
power so in order to overcome the
limitations of these sources i
instead turn to grassroots data and to
explain how i'm doing this let me tell
you
a quick story so one day i was doing
research in the city of iwo and i was
visiting a flea market
on the outskirts of town and while
walking from stall to stall and i was
kind of you know digging through
uh different kinds of socialist
memorabilia mao badges
and you know ration coupons and stuff
like that
i came across this big stack of brown
jacketed dossiers
so i pick up the folder on top of the
pile and i begin flipping through the
contents
and inside were government reports
written during the cultural revolution
on black markets underground factories
and other quote unquote spontaneous
capitalist activities so i got really
excited
when i saw these documents and i bought
them all without haggling
uh very much and i asked the vendor if
he had more um so he shared with me his
uh wechat
info and then he invited me back to his
home in anway
so the next week i went to his home at
this
little apartment at the edge of town and
inside
the apartment were just pillars of
documents stacked from floor
to ceiling except for this tiny space in
the living room that had been carved out
for a tea table
the rest of the apartment was chock full
of historical materials including
former government archives still in
their brown
paper jackets so
i ended up uh procuring some of these
materials and for the next five years i
networked with communities of document
merchants
uh from whom i uh assembled thousands of
documents
related to underground capitalism in
socialist china
so in the course of procuring these
documents i was fortunate enough to come
by
two exceptionally complete collections
of more than uh 2500 cases of
so-called speculation and profiteering
prosecuted by two local administrations
in china
so here's just a picture of some of the
documents that belong to that collection
and each case focuses on the
investigation of people like these men
who were
arrested for engaging in various types
of illicit commerce
and underground production in this case
uh you know they're selling
coupons and things ration coupons so the
cases involved
all manner of goods um from poached furs
to smuggled wristwatches
to arms and munitions
and most uh and most importantly for me
and and the purposes of
my work most included some kind of case
summary
like this that outline the type of
illicit activities
where and when they occurred and what
types of goods were involved
now in addition to examining many of
these cases
in meticulous detail i also try to view
them from a distance
i abstract their contents into data
and then i use this data to build
microeconomic data sets
so to explain how let me use this case
summary as
a quick illustration so the case
summaries provide
all types of information that are useful
to generate data
so in the first line of text here you
know we are told that the prosecuted
individual is a male 56 years of age
born into a poor peasant household
and he's a member of the bay people's
commune
so we can code this information into
categories like gender
age class status and institutional
affiliation
uh from the second paragraph we learned
that the individual between the years of
1973 and 1976
sold six head of cow for a total
of 1127 rmb
so we can similarly code this data and
then finally in the third paragraph
uh we learned that he was punished with
a fine of 500 rmb
so from this type of information we can
derive the proportional level of
punishment so we can take that 500
by a 500 rmb divided by the total case
value 1127.
so you get that the economic fine in
this case was equal to
44 of the total reported case value
and although it's not in this example
many cases also
include information about the origin and
terminus
of illicit economic activity that we can
code into geospatial data
so over the course of almost two years i
went through
all 2600 cases in my data set
this particular data set and manually
coded their contents into
you know something that looks like this
and and use them to create what i
believe are the largest
data sets on illicit economic activity
in socialist china
uh there were all sorts of challenges in
this process uh
dealing with missing data incomplete
data um
and i won't go into that here but i'm
happy to talk more about that in the q
a if anyone's interested so what does
the data tell us
um first the data set reveals something
about the scale
of these illicit economic activities if
we look at the summary statistics uh for
the two counties that i have
uh analyzed here we find that the mean
value of goods described in the cases
was on the order of three to five
hundred
rmb moreover the
average amount of cash
seized in the cases was about 100 rmb
so these are pretty huge numbers for
this period uh to put those into
perspective the mean
annual consumption of a rural worker was
about 100 rmb a year
and the annual disposal income of
urban work i mean was really a lot lower
still around 10 to 20
rmb per year so in other words there's a
lot of cash
flowing in this illicit economy and the
mean entrepreneur
was not you know a farmer selling a
couple of chickens
at the market i mean it's a specialized
producer or trader who is dealing in
quantities of goods
whose value represent multiple years of
consumption of the mean worker
so the data set also provides insight
into the spatial scope
of entrepreneurial activity so here i've
represented the spatial distribution of
network connections
for the two counties uh in this
particular data set
and as we can see the illicit activity
do not just occur within socialist
administrative units
but they they you know go across them
so there's a distinguishable core
cluster from these two counties
with that reaches out to more distal
connections
places as far away as sichuan and the
west and heilongjiang in the north
and if we zoom in on the core cluster we
find that the network
extending from these two counties
completely crosses
uh provincial lines and in no way really
conforms to prefectural or provincial
boundaries
and just impressionistically if we
compare the results of this core cluster
to say william skinner's classical
delineation of
physiographical macro regions we find
that
the area of illicit networks that i've
mapped out in these two counties
conforms really well to the
lower yongsa macro region so from this
type of spatial evidence we can
at least begin to infer that economic
activity was probably shaped more by
topographical features
and traditional merchant networks than
by socialist
administrative boundaries more work will
need to be done here though as i
add in more counties from different
provinces into my data set
but finally and most interestingly i
think the data reveals that local
governments
did not faithfully execute central
government directives
for suppressing private entrepreneurial
activity so in the 1960s the central
government
directives basically stated that all
goods acquired
through private illicit activities
should be seized by government agencies
and that the severity of punishment for
the convicted
speculators and profiteers should scale
in accordance
with the aggregate value of their
illicit activity
in other words the bigger the activity
the bigger the punishment
however what we find in the data is that
the patterns of punishment were almost
exactly the opposite
so if we divide the cases into temporal
cohorts
like this as i've done here we noticed
two really surprising things
first we see that in the sample only a
handful of people received any form of
extra monetary punishment
in other words when individuals were
caught engaging illicit activities
they were really only punished by and
large
with fines very few people were sent to
jail
sent to labor camp or even you know like
publicly criticized
this was true even during the cultural
revolution period
second and equally surprising even when
entrepreneurs
were punished with seizures and fines
the majority of goods were actually
returned to them so you can see that in
the column percent returned in every
cohort
we have more than half the goods half
the value of the goods being returned to
the entrepreneurs
so what's going on here and if you read
through the individual cases as i've
done what you
you start coming across a lot uh the
phrase
a lot which literally means to procure
at you know a given price turn into a
price and procure it
and so what was happening was that
instead of seizing goods from
entrepreneurs outright
government officials were forcibly
procuring them at low prices
but in effect this meant that the local
governments were taxing the goods
uh and that entrepreneurs were being
left with enough capital to effectively
continue their private pursuits
if we dig deeper into the data we find
that the size of seizure and fines
was actually inversely proportional to
the total value
of illicit economic activity in other
words the bigger the activity
the lighter the punishment and this
directly contravenes
those central directives and this was
true in both of my observed
administrations moreover
punishments were not uniform as they
were supposed to be
um if you divide up the types of
punishments based on you know various
factors as i've done here
we find that the illicit exchange of
ration coupons
was far more likely to be dealt with
severely than you know the illicit
exchange of agricultural products or
consumer goods
so this demonstrates that officials were
being calculative
and selective in their enforcement
practices
they chose what types of activities to
punish
and they chose which ones to tolerate
and based on my individual cases i i
really take this
reading of these individual cases i take
this to mean that local officials
were really interested in protecting
activities that they viewed as being
productive in the local economy
while punishing those such as you know
ration coupon trading that they thought
were really unproductive and frustrated
their efforts to
you know move around resources so
collectively my dude uh data i think
demonstrates that illicit
entrepreneurial activity
was a lot bigger and a lot more
permissible
than previous scholarship suggests while
formal economic institutions
during the socialist era may have been
explicitly designed to divide and
control
the economy socialist entrepreneurs
found all kinds of ways to effectively
circumvent
these institutions and help facilitate
flows of capital
labor and knowledge and in doing so they
even gradually won
the tacit support of local officials uh
so that was a very rough kind of
synopsis of the paper that i'm currently
working on
i'm happy to go into detail later on
anything that you find more interesting
but i hope this at least gives a flavor
of how the sources and the methods that
i'm
bringing to the table here are offering
a different vantage from which
to understand socialist economic
practice thank you very much
thank you adam so um the last
presentation is mine
so where
so um my paper today sort of look at
a very similar question as uh adams
so i'm looking at the origins of the
xiaokan society
the kind of the kind of ideology that
came after
uh the decline of maoism in contemporary
china
uh i'm looking at this the birth of the
sake of society
as a socio-economic phenomenon that
um that as as a social economic product
of the maoist uh cultural russian
so the central question of this paper is
why did china abruptly turn out
turn away from communists in the night
in the late 1970s
and never really turned back uh what was
the social
post associate's new order so what is
what is
uh what is the nature of this xiaokang
society that came after the communist
order
and why was the new order so durable so
even today
xi jinping he was still talking about
how china
has fulfilled the primary goal of the
xiaokon society
so the basic question is about the
historical dynamics that leads to
the decline of communism and the rights
of the xiaokong society
previous scholarship have talked about
it from a
variety of perspectives like elite
politics how the cultural revolution
actually
led to downfall of common system the
rise of technocratic elites
china's shifting geopolitical strategies
in the cold war
and as adam shows a bold app source of
entrepreneurship
even during the maoist era
so the perspective that i proposed to
examine this
uh the dynamics were everyday life
so what kind of afterlife ever the life
dynamics were there
in particular i'm looking at family
state relations in urban china
so to understand family state
relationship in
the maui china i think it's pivotal to
conceptualize this period as a period of
what i call a period of revolutionary
austerity
so basically i'm talking about this long
period uh from 1962 so basically after
the gravity forward failure
to the start of reform and so-called
period of
revolutionary austerity so so by
revolution austerity
uh basically means state family
redistribution
of income uh under the common economy
so basically the state common state were
forcefully
redistributing income national income
from the livelihood and reproduct
reproduction of urban household two
state strategies
like defense uh and third front uh
surf fund constructions and and diploma
and diplomatic expandings
so why was this uh austerity a
revolutionary austerity
first because it's a direct result of
the physical impact
of the great leaf and the cultural
revolution
and then because the whole mobilization
of
urban families to sacrifice for states
political objectives were mobilized and
sustained
consistently by cold war ideological
mobilizations
such as anti-revisionism and the
pretarian
consolidation and the cult revolution
so i divided it into two phase the first
phase was basically
before the establishment of urban
communes in 1968 and second phase
uh was basically the face of the sun
down movement
uh so the key measures of these
austerities
uh i summarize it as four so first
there's a
major urban wage freeze which basically
frees urban wage of all levels
between 1963 and 1977
there was massive laying off and the job
freeze for two periods
first uh as a direct um result of
gravity ford and then
uh during the first uh the first phase
of the cult revolution
and then there was massive
investigations sending down people from
the cities to the countryside
first as a downsizing in the early 60s
and then as the sundown movement in the
70s
and the fourthly the birth control which
was introduced into
urban china basically in the middle 60s
so all those measures
were forcefully imposed on the urban
households
so today so as they measured to save uh
state spending
uh on the urban household livelihood and
reproduction
so um so basically um the physical
rationales of the revolution austerity
we can analyze it into like um
uh two components the first component
was economic cost so basically the state
was trying to
force upon the urban household economic
cost of failed
political movement first is definitely
the great effort which cost up to 60
percent of the market
in 1961 and then during the early phase
of cultural illusion again
because of the chaos that were produced
in the first phase of cultural
revolution
there were lots of budget revenue
amount to 25 in the year between 1966
and 1968
and then there was also this the more
durable
economic costs of china's cultural
mobilizations uh
especially during the 1970s when china
was expanding big amounts
on funding revolutionary programs
worldwide
on building up its military uh in
anticipation of a
a huge confrontation of soviet union
and building up the third front so all
those spending if you add together it
takes up
um almost half of the national budget
in the 1970s so this is a
graph that tells us a bit about the
impact of the political movement
so these are the um the revenues
uh so we can see that
there was a big jump first during the
great d4 and then the sharp four
and then there is a bit of recovery in
the early 60s and then followed up
another big four
in the cultural revolution
and this is the share of military budget
so
in the in the national market and gdp so
we can see that
there were um so after the end of the
war
uh it was it has been maintained at a
very high level of
over 15 during much of this time
and then declined gradually forced into
like five
or six percent in the early 60s
but most importantly i think we need to
understand impact in terms of
the supply of urban jobs because in the
comment economy urban jobs need a
means a almost lifelong employment with
a small basket of social
security and with
a guaranteed to promote a guaranteed
promotion of incomes
as the workers get promoted on their
skill level
so basically you can see that after the
grade e4 there's a shop for
uh marked by the great the mass
downsizing of
urban workers to the countryside and
then again
in this in the late 60s and early 70s
there was another big four
so basically there was a huge shot for
urban jobs during this period especially
the early period
early period of the austerity it only
became to
recover a bit in the middle 70s
but talking about adult security as a
this huge
big political and economic project
we can perhaps situate some down
movement at the center of this whole
process
because it active epitomized the whole
process is
in all its dimensions so the sundown
policy in shanghai if we
compare the scale is about five percent
eight percent of national total so
basically shanghai was where
the sun down policy was most rigorously
implemented
uh in terms of the physical impact it's
a huge
reduction in wage spending for the
government so basically
the government can save a huge uh
according to my estimation 400 million
or 50 percent of the revenue in shanghai
during the 70s by just sending down
employable workers uh
young students and used to the
countryside
so they need to frequent feed themselves
it was also a part of the continuous
revolution first as a continuation of
pre-1949 ccp economic programs like the
great construct uh great construction
programs in yemen
it's also managed to flatten the urban
rural wage gaps
and it was measured to preempt the
virtualization of the use
and finally it'll it can also be viewed
in the context of cold war
as a war preparation against imperial
powers especially soviet union
uh as a relocation of manpower from
cities in an anticipation of an
air strike or the male or other major
war movement
and also as an effort to stop
the 12 huge frontier military farms that
are built up
in the 96 and 70s along china's
uh northwest southwest northeast from
tears
so these are the uh kind of slogans they
used to inspire the youth
to sacrifice for the country
by going down to the countryside so
if we look at this issue from families
perspective then
we can find that sundance women at least
have
three type of costs on families economic
costs
first as a cost of resettlement because
the family need to afford for the basic
equipment
and sometimes even food stock for for
for the
for the youngsters to go to the
countryside but more important
it is the cost comes up as a future
loss the loss of future urban job
incomes because they basically lost
their guaranteed employment in the in
the cities
and then it came as emotional cost first
as the pure pain of family separation
and then induced economic strength and
the emotional cost
at home and lastly it also came at a
longer reproductive cost
because by separating the families
separating the generations
there's definitely a delayed marriage
and and childbirth
due to the all sorts of uncertainties
so um the case i'm presenting today is
the hwang family uh
basically a huawei family uh that i
found
really interesting from the food and
center of country china social life data
and research
is a huge um it's one of the latter
collections seven letter collections
that i mobilized for this research
project but huawei family letter
came as really interesting because it
represents
uh jordan's own letters to his daughters
um
and other relatives for um
during this uh whole almost whole
austerity period uh between 19 middle
60s
to the late 70s um and when i was
actually a very average worker um level
four
on skill level and working and earning
around 80 yen
months and he's a single breadwinner
with his wife being laid off
from the neighborhood production
production teams
after the grady ford and then they had
to feed about
uh four children two of them were
grown-up daughters
who were sent down to the countryside
one to janine and another
jiangshi in the late 1960s and early 70s
so these letters reflected on the
everyday political and economic concerns
of the family
and they also reflect the kind of
grassroots ideologies that
we want to examine as the basis of this
childcare society
so basically from this uh compilation of
data from the letters we can see
how the sundown movement during the
first period of two years
had a huge impact on family finance
whereas the income um because of the
wage freeze was stationary at
85 yuan per month you can see
uh right
they had afford like 400 400 yen just to
send down
their two dollars in the first two years
so that's about five
five five five months income but also it
represents almost five to six years of
the savings
so basically they depleted the savings
in order to just afford
the initial stage of sundown movement
and beyond that they need to borrow
actually from the families and
also the work unit so this is the kind
of
family supporting networks where they
collected the basic resources
to uh for the sundown for the sundown of
the
of two eldest daughters
so basically they are relying very
heavily on both the work unit
which acted more like precautionary
saving institutions
um and moreover they were relying on the
um
on the families the relatives especially
the father
the parents involved
so how did what family compared
situation compared to other families
uh i selected like um five families from
this archive of
workers in the shanghai united united
front department so these are
five workers who received subsidies in
1973
and in fact we if we compare the
situations between
and all those five workers their
situation pretty similar
they all had like at least one children
being sent down and they were all
like families one really just one brand
winner
and you can see that by the middle 70s
they were basically um
barely surviving under the amiga income
this is their per capita income which is
actually below
the um stipulated average of 20 20
20 yuan and sometimes even below the
uh the um 15 15 grand that was these
basics like subsidy income
but the impact of descending movement
and austerities
measures goes beyond uh just purely
economic impact it also impacts the
family
reproductive strategies so basically why
had his daughters
two of his daughters actually delayed
the marriage one of them uh eventually
married in jining
but uh without ever um returning back to
shanghai
uh until 1976 uh so
so so so basically um if we calculate
the whole family's uh
spendings and their uh reproductive
strategies then
we can see that eventually by 1975
their families economic situations
actually improved because there were
fewer children being born almost no
children
being born in the early 1970s
and the family size just gets smaller so
if you compare to the whole situation in
shanghai then it hua family situation
was actually quite typical
because if you compare the whole
situation is that in the early 60s the
um shanghai was the economy with very
high dependency ratio of 73.7 uh 3.7
3.7 the federal rate was almost four
and and and the angle coefficient was 80
um
58 but by the late
70s uh the dependence rate has fallen to
1.7 1.5
1.5 and it's actually kept falling tier
1.1
in the early 80s the fertility rate was
reduced to 1.2
and angle coefficient has improved to
about
just 32. so basically what happened to
the mindset of the people out there
um so after years of those economic
frustrations and all those burdens
um quadrupling began to realize that
what was the cause of the whole problem
and it became the articulate those
issues with his own
friends so as the economy of the week he
was talking about her economy
and also his family economy they remain
in government they simply let people
bear the burden the sundown movement
will leave me in that for eight years i
will try to pay off the outstanding debt
in 1976
reboot my family economy and rebuild the
battle of family shall come to your
social country first appeared in all the
letter sets i have
examined at the source of articulation
of a new vision of
of the families but more importantly it
appears also
in grassroots opinion surveys so if you
look at survey of materials
um 80 80 80 of the survey
sent down use in 1978
um articulated that they felt a sense of
economic victimhood during this
uh sundown era about 75 young workers
who were surveyed in 1980s during the
shanghai department of propaganda survey
articulated that they regarded family
welfare as the prime important
uh as more important than politics and
all other concerns in their life
and they feel much less about class
consciousness than the older generations
during their own generations experience
in the 1670s
although to remind us these generations
were actually the red children
who in fact grew up in the high mountain
of 1970s and 60s and yet they were
the also the generation who rejected uh
this whole conception of class
consciousness
um and at the official level we can see
that there's a
new discourse of family as a foundation
of political order so first i'm joking's
idea of xiao kang
as the goal of china's modernization so
basically it reflects
what the gracious opinion has been
calling for and articulating for
almost five to four years in the middle
seventies
it also reflects well-balanced
articulation that each families
sell and basically the foundation of
the national body politics
so um these are another two uh uh
vignette from family letters that shows
what kind of political opinions the
people felt
uh about the situations from a
shanghainese sundown youth who are
strangled in uh in hui and um
he was basically he was uh promoted to a
factory outfit but never returned to
shanghai until the middle eighties
so just like you said he was writing to
his fiance
political struggles are simply
meaningless struggles for powers
and the grassroots class must have their
own opinions
of every uh issue based on clear
understanding of our self-interest
and then i used to consider yourself a
marxist and leader at maximum but things
here are always beyond their
explanations
so after so many years of struggle
what they reach is the conclusion that
which is like that is actually that
their supreme ideal in the highest
happiness in life
is not the communist visions but the
witness in their baby our best qualities
that he realized our unrealized uh
dreams
and stand tall among his peers so we can
see this kind of competitive parenthood
is already bubbling in the
grassroots mindset by the late seventies
so what is nature of the afghan society
first is that the politicization
is it means the end of mass politics and
the consistently
uh as a consistent state strategy and
ideology
and then it means it also means a more
natural base of power
so the communist regime was no longer
based on communism
and vision but actually effectively
based on parental care and sacrifice for
their children
it also means a new ideology of
development as a family wealth
accumulation so the family can share the
wealth and they can see the futures
in the national development and
ultimately it means the family has a new
unit of button up mobilizations
through inter-generation sacrifice so
basically continuous revolution
was still alive but only in economic
in terms of economic organizations so in
conclusion
the paradox of revolution austerity was
that it basically
ended the continuous revolution as mao
has proposed
but at the same time they actually
transformed the family life and made
urban families a new dynamo
of economic economic mobilizations in
postmod china
and at the same time transformed urban
family state relations
from kind of pure dominations and
absorptions
into a class-based society to
a situation where the state has to rely
on mobilization and sacrifice of
families
in order for its economic development
and uh
ultimate and finally we want to
highlight family letters as a key source
for studying this kind of relations
thank you
i'm sorry for over time
so i'll go ahead and introduce myself my
name is denise ho
and i've been asked to serve as
discussant today so i will offer some
brief remarks and then we'll open up to
general q
a so firstly uh just thank you for the
panelists for including me in this
fascinating body of work
um i think i speak for others in the
field when
i i say that reading the inspirational
scholarship of the next generation of
leading historians
is one of the most rewarding parts of my
job so thank you for reminding me
why i do what i do um so
as for the papers as for the panel as a
totality i think we can address
three common themes and the first theme
is going to be the largest
and the second i'll give a bit less
attention to
the first theme is that the papers
invite us to
revisit the economic history of not only
maoist china and afterward as the title
suggests
but also this longer arc of what the
economy meant
in modern chinese history second i think
all of the papers
invite us to continue to pay attention
to ideology in our analysis
of contemporary china and then finally
the papers remind us
to draw on a diversity of sources and an
increasing body of sources and adam and
yenja in particular
demonstrate what kind of work can be
done with new source bases
so first the largest umbrella revisiting
the economic history
of modern china
under this i have a first category of
economic experience and the context
for economic experience all four of the
papers are in their own way about
overturning previous assumptions
about economic activity in the mao era
and after
or in the mao era in its transition to
the reform era
adam makes the convincing argument that
entrepreneurship persisted in socialist
china
that it was far larger in scale and more
extensive than had been claimed he can
quantify it
it crossed administrative boundaries and
it was tacitly permitted by local
officials
an attitude he suggests was known to the
people engaging in entrepreneurship
gavin shows how the service industry
persisted in mouse china
though in the 1970s the the very
definition of service or foo
and the people it would serve underwent
a transformation
additionally tourist service pivoted
from being an act of revolutionary
diplomacy
to one of modernization yenja's paper
examines how ordinary families
experience the financial burdens
of the sent down youth movement showing
how a central state
policy resulted in shifting financial
burdens from the state to the family
and economic costs that created family
debts created family tensions
and ultimately led away led to a turn
from
rhetoric revolutionary rhetoric towards
a primary concern
with a family's financial well-being
and then finally peter's paper
integrates a history of management
education
a history of overseas chinese investment
and an analysis
of how management was theorized and
taught to create links
between the mao era and after and also
between china or among china hong kong
and north american business schools
another category worth highlighting
under this this larger umbrella of
economic history
is the role of geography
so each of the papers has a different
geographic
lens um one that both widens and
contracts
in his paper adam takes his data and
visualizes on a map
showing how transactions transcended
geographic boundaries
and perhaps retraced historic trading
networks despite the maoist ideal of
atarki
gavin's paper also has a geographic
dimension and this aspect comes out even
more so in his upcoming dissertation
with its analysis of the railway workers
who serve on the guangzhou shenzhen
railway line
it is in this mobility that his service
workers sort out the meaning of service
and the meaning of serving the people
while yenja's paper starts and ends in
shanghai
he invites us to revisit our perceptions
of the urban rural divide
we have conventionally thought of sent
down youth movement as one in which the
state
offloads excess labor and puts the
burden on the countryside
but here the burden is actually put back
on the family in the city
so it reframes our geographic thinking
about the sent down movement
and then finally peter's paper extends
the analysis of his recently published
book
on trans-pacific networks to this
establishment of mba programs
by american universities and with the
help of elite
hong kong graduates
another category worth thinking about
when we put all these four papers
uh side by side is a category of
periodization
and all of the papers have an attention
to
both the historical narrative and the
creation of that historical narrative
in their perspective topics
adam does this in two ways he shows uh
that entrepreneurship persisted across
1949
and that the reform era entrepreneurship
was not released by the policies
of reform and opening up but was rather
preceded
by a wave of entrepreneurship that began
in the mid-1970s
adam is also used is able to use data to
show how activity doesn't just decline
after so-called socialist transformation
but that it comes in waves
despite the interruptions in bureaucracy
created by the cultural revolution
gavin's research invites us to think
about periodization
by framing perhaps periods of socialism
and high socialism
or a long and short cultural revolution
thus the early 1970s for gavin is the
beginning of a transformation in the
service industry
one that also maps on to china's
admission to the united nations
yenja's paper periodizes in two ways
on a specific level he links the sent
down you
experience with youth discontent in the
years after
so a transition periodization
but on a longer time scale and this
comes out more so in the paper than in
the presentation
he connects a long history of what xiao
kang meant
with deng xiaoping's reformulation of
xiao kang for the era of reform
and finally peter's study of management
management education
particular particularly in the paper a
close reading of the textbook
industrial enterprise management shows
how the history of mao era
scientific management was rewritten for
the age of educating a new generation
of managers and entrepreneurs
under this larger category of economic
history i want to mention two other
subcategories briefly
in the interest of time related to the
category of geographic space
there's a theme of connections with the
world outside of china
highlighted particularly in gavin and
peter's work
and secondly an important theme in the
study of economic history
there's this idea of family and
intergenerational relationships
something that yenja's paper calls our
attention to
that is if one aspect of chinese
business history is
the role of the corporate family and if
mau-era policies have been seen as
disrupting family networks or family
strategies
yenjias shows us how families continue
to strategize
as a family to maximize their economic
well-being in the mao period
the second category or the second theme
is the importance of ideology
i want to underscore how all these
papers demonstrate the
continued importance of using ideology
to analyze the experience
of chinese socialism and after for adam
ideology is one of the entry points he
can trace the reoccurrences
of speculation and profiteering in the
people's daily
and then he can show how despite
rhetoric to the contrary local officials
did not prosecute cases in a way that
reflected the rhetoric
for gavin the ideological tension of
service work is something that
his historical actors have to grapple
with and throughout his paper and
throughout
the longer dissertation he traces the
political meaning
of tourism and the tourist industry
for yenjia the research question is to
understand the ways in which
popular sentiment shifted and how
ideological slogans reflected
such sentiments and for peter in his own
words
the existence of the mba programs seemed
to pose a paradox
and the ideological acrobatics of the
management text becomes a way
to explore the meaning of management in
the era of reform
and then finally uh as yenji did at the
end of his presentation
i want to highlight the use of new
sources
and applaud the panelists for their
research methods
each in their own way is doing a form of
grassroots history
an aggregation of personal experience
from the shanghai family
to the rural entrepreneur to the railway
worker to the mba student
in particular adam's work calls for the
building of micro data sets
from grassroots data so i urge you to
read the paper if it's publicly
available
and also to watch his presentation for
the stanford con
conference on chinese archives in crisis
so data and mapping becomes increasingly
important in thinking about new
directions
for contemporary chinese history and
finally
yenja's paper makes exceptional and
pioneering work with mao era personal
letters
providing an intimate glimpse into both
family relationships
and even a history of family emotions
and
secondly the mentalities of the reform
era experience
so in the interest of time i'm only
going to ask a couple questions of each
panelist
and i'm sure many more will come out in
the q a
um so adam i already got to ask you a
series of questions after the stanford
conference
so perhaps you can indulge me by
thinking about a more technical question
so when i was reading your analysis of
the local officials
on page 25 and 26 of the paper i was
thinking about
things like customs violations and
smuggling
so if you read let's say customs
gazetteers from the 1990s
their descriptions of what goods were
still able to pass through customs
if they were illegal because they were
needed
so one one case of this is
pharmaceuticals so customs officials
would look the other way
if there was a particular medicine that
was scarce in china
and as i was listening to your
presentation i was thinking about some
archival documents i've seen
where you have purchase price lists at
customs
with often things like small electronic
goods and so on that the customs
officials are buying
um from travelers who are bringing in
more than they're allowed to bring in
um so in your analysis is this parallel
to local officials treatment of
entrepreneurship
or are imported goods to be understood
in a different category
in one of your final slides you showed
how agriculture and consumer goods were
not punished
in the same way as other other items so
could we look at these
customs imported goods in that same um
same vein um a sec
a question for gavin um so um
i just kind of by coincidence i read
your paper right after peter's paper
and so i wanted to ask you more about
tourism textbooks and tourism education
i noticed that in your presentation you
showed us a photograph
of a of a handbook for tourism workers
um and so thinking through peter's
analysis of management education
can you tell us more about tourism
education and how it changed
uh in your period for the presentations
today and perhaps even after
when did schools of tourism appear and
do they have any parallels
to other forms of education in the
reform era transition
um for yenji i was hoping to ask you a
methodological question
one of the things you did really well in
the paper is to link the very different
kinds of sources
on the one hand you have you
showed us slides where you were
aggregating data from
labor gazetteers but then
when you look at the family letters
especially in your paper these are
really about
intimate family relationships and
emotions and conflicts within the family
so i wanted to ask you about what are
the methodological
opportunities and challenges of dealing
with very very different kinds
of data um
and then finally uh peter uh
you ended your paper with a number of
questions that you hope to answer
in the future to follow up on your
conclusion i was thinking of
two questions one of them was have you
found out more since about the ways
in which textbooks were written my
ignorant understanding of mba training
in the us is that it's based on this
case method
so was this a way of teaching adapted to
the chinese context and how
what kinds of businesses were used as
cases
when one was studying in management in
china
and then as a second question your
conclusion got me thinking about
financial journalism
so does financial journalism develop in
tandem or
after management education do you find
similar ties with hong kong
i'm thinking about economic reporting
coming out of south china for example
what's the justification and theory of
financial journalism
and which is often seen as something
that pushes the envelope on reporting
in contemporary china so
perhaps what we can do is invite each um
each panelist to respond to
these questions or the discussion
comments
and then we'll gather uh some of the q a
that i'm seeing popping up
in the q a function
and uh thank you dennis for this really
generous and
insightful comments i think you can
start with uh
uh maybe galvin and then we go around in
the same order
all right thank you angie and thank you
denise for those those comments um
i think um first i'll answer your your
specific question
about the tourism training um i had the
good fortune to spend
a year um in china doing field work as a
sort of visiting student at one of the
tourism schools at um
at sunyan sen university in guangzhou
and um
and of course what we were what the
students there are studying is a much
much higher level um about sort of sort
of
the sociology and economics of tourism
and not sort of so much the practical
training
but we definitely see in kind of roughly
around the time of the four
modernizations the late 1970s
we see in shanghai in beijing and
guangzhou
the first sort of like practical tourism
training schools um coming into being
and i think the first model um and the
first model for many
sort of things in china um in the new
china is
the sort of the soviet model and so in
the 50s and even to the early 60s we see
much of the learning about how to sort
of do the business of tourism
coming from the sort of the model of
interest which existed in the soviet
union since the 1920s
and after the sort of the soviet model
is no longer
sort of is now revisionist a lot of the
training initially a lot of the
circulation of knowledge is through
really through direct
observation so it's sort of seeking
truth from from facts it's a direct
observation of the tourists themselves
and so guides are taking notes not just
on the
uh sort of the reactions of tourists to
sort of like the political reactions of
tourists but also on their
reactions to service and like trying to
learn
like directly from the reactions of of
foreign tourists and
um i mean i think finally what we see in
the 70s and 80s and this i think really
relates to what
what peter talked about is we really see
the importance of hong kong
because hong kong was always sort of the
the entry point
for tourists into china i mean the vast
majority of tourists are coming
you know into china from hong kong and
the vast majority of the tourists are
you know residents of hong kong and um
so we're seeing a lot of learning coming
from hong kong we're seeing like in the
early 80s
hotels in shanghai are sending chefs to
hong kong hotels to
to train they're also um the early
particularly as as china's tourism grows
there's
the the main constraint is the lack of
hotels
and so the hong kong investors sort of
play a really critical role
in financing hotels and also in
designing and managing
um those hotels so i mean that's what i
would say to that specific question
um you gave us you gave me so many other
things that i could talk about i don't
want to take too much time
from the others but one thing i do want
to want to highlight which i didn't
really get a chance to sort of highlight
so much
in in my talk today because of the time
constraints was
really the role of gender in service and
um
and i think that relates to the the
economics of tourism as well
i mean people particularly men do not
want to be service workers
it's primarily because they see it as
women's work and they say it's a sector
dominated by
by women and so and they they repeatedly
complain about how it
sort of damages their sort of marriage
prospects
so i mean and i mean that goes for the
men but even even women engaged in in
service industry really see it as a dead
end it's an unskilled labor
so as this and i think this also leads
to what ian is talking about as we have
more and more
sort of use coming back into the urban
workforce in the late 70s
we have to sort of funnel more of them
into service trades and that sort of
sector
really doubles in employment in from
1978 to 1982
so there's a lot of new ways to sort of
try to make it more acceptable and
to people and one of the ways is through
sort of professionalization uh
you know you know of it and i think that
sort of the ideology
of professionalization really does feed
into like how we justify
um you know how do we reconcile people's
sort of like aspirations with the
reality of the
the labor market at that time thank you
thank you so much for those those great
questions and comments um
and uh take do them in the reverse order
uh the financial journalism something is
something i have not thought about
at all so that's that's really
interesting um
as to the intellectual and potential
personnel
links there you know thinking about
magazines or other publications like
saijiang and their origins and the kind
of knowledge that you would need to have
in order to
pursue financial journalism um but i
really don't know that much about
that aspect of it that's a new avenue to
go down
um the textbooks is really interesting
because
um and there's a lot going on there
because i think that
industrial enterprise management was the
textbook
in the chinese language for a lot of the
1980s it goes to a ton of editions i
haven't
gotten my hands on all of the editions
and it seems to be
a prestigious thing um to be appointed
to the council
that's writing the textbook and they're
selecting a kind of expanding
number of of co-authors to revise the
various editions
of this text but then when we get to the
90s and the partnership and
the transition towards mba programs
there's this
interesting kind of bifurcation because
in particular the programs that
fudan and changhua pride themselves on
being in english
and the textbooks they continue to use
are primarily the exact same textbook
as mit or other one uh other
other programs you know in the the
managerial communications textbook being
one example or data models and decisions
uh but data models and decisions which
i didn't go into too far has a number of
translations some which seem to be
authorized and some of which seem to be
unauthorized
and the whole point of data models and
decisions is to work through specific
cases
so the involved faculty have talked
about the in the authorized translations
they have begun to
choose new chinese cases that are more
closely tailored to what students will
anticipate and experience in the future
um
but oftentimes the translation is just
an exact translation of the
the english version uh so there's
similarly more work that i can do there
some of which goes out of my time frame
you know this is
this is the last chapter of the project
um so we'll see where i end up
um but thank you the both of those are
great avenues to
continue researching on
so maybe adam
sorry uh yeah i know uh that's that's a
interesting question about
the uh the goods that are being smuggled
through
and then like the permissibility of
those goods i absolutely i think we can
treat them the exact same way
as the other types of goods that i'm
looking at so one thing i'm doing with
my data set
right now is that i've taken all of the
goods that have been seized by officials
and i'm organizing them into the
classification systems
that were created by government
officials so class one class two
and then class three goods and then in
that we also have which
um administrative departments oversee
uh the management of particular types of
goods like the
the grain departments over grain and
then cotton's controlled but anyway
so and so forth um and i'm looking at
how
these different types of goods are
variably
controlled uh in the economy
i think we can do the exact same thing
with the custom networks
um yeah i'll stop there i'll i want to
answer some of the questions that people
have brought up so i'll leave time for
that
thank you dennis for this wonderful
question i think it's a
it's actually a very challenging one so
i i will seek to
provide my very humble opinion only on
this methodology
question i think um with the current
political situations uh
it become incredibly difficult really to
secure a complete certified
sources that goes all the way from like
uh
provincial or even central level
archives to graduate
sources and increasingly we need uh to
rely on grassroots sources that
uh we have no direct control actually so
we basically
work on what we chanced upon sometimes
so um so there's definitely some kind of
challenge
so so my approach to this question is
that
um first is we need to look at
uh gross resources as a new type of uh
challenge to uh the historical protect
your profession because it uh um
raises new ethical questions about the
use
so we need to um so the most urgency
actually
for grassroots historians especially for
people like me who are working on
private sources is that what kind of
protocols uh privacy protocols that we
need to adopt
adopt in order to protect privacy of the
um
i'll say the latter writers or the
diaries
or some people who have some petition
address to doc
to the work units um the second question
is
is the basic or immediate challenge of
course sources that is is often
incomplete scattered and sometimes
extremely
extremely idiosyncratic i think adam did
a fabulous job of compiling
uh almost a whole data set from two
companies but that's
very rare among you know grassroots
works because most people
do you don't have this uh sometimes you
you don't you just don't have these
complete connections
so the question is how to work with more
scattered
sources of more scattered nature um and
my experience is that um we need to
keeping uh keep in mind the kind of
the question of scale and the question
of
information bureaucracy that is how
the kind of informations were gathered
from grassroots sources
reflect only a certain issues or certain
aspects of certain issues
at a certain locale so we need to
contextualize it really carefully with
sources from archives and other sources
or
macro or data and then we need to bear
in mind that
it's really a very small piece of the
whole information system
that is like chunking out millions of
documents
private and public every day so
basically we need to like
piece up the jig.puzzle to know where
are the missing
puzzles and where our information will
actually contribute
to the kind of larger uh kind of
information
network that was operating in in in
mouse china
so so basically that's my that's my
answer and i'll
keep on thinking about your question
later
thank you
so we had a i see we had a lot of
questions
we have a lot of questions um and about
20 minutes remaining so
um maybe what we can do is have a first
branch of
two questions per speaker um that you
can answer as you wish
and then um uh and and then we can go to
a
second round of questions if we have
time um so
let's see peter you have um i'm
mostly choosing in the the order in
which they came
in um you have a question
from scrolling through here you have a
question from koji hirata and isabella
jackson
um uh isabella asks
uh could you please tell us more about
the students
in this in the these mba programs
and koji asks
i assume many of the students in
management education were employed by
soes rather than private enterprises
did the dominant still dominant
presidents of soviets in china
influenced the content of
nba education in a substantial way
also were these programs related to
jurongji's soe reform in any way
um so let's do two questions for peter
um two questions for yandia
we have one from sarah chang
um the question has to do with state
family relations
the scholars of the socialist period
sometimes characterize the connection
between state and family as a mutual
embeddedness
where the family was a smaller cell
within a larger production regime
would you say this relation is radically
different in a xiaokong society
does the family break out of this
relation with the state what bearing
does this have on contemporary china
um and uh
a second question from koji
koji hirata is the dungest version
vision of
xiaokong society related to the one
child policy
in any way
then let's see two questions for adam
um i don't know if adam you would prefer
to choose them
um or go with the first two that came in
uh it's either fine okay
uh well if we go with the first two that
came in uh we have one from one joe
um
i wonder if you tried to look for these
people engaged in such activities or
their relatives to learn more about how
being caught
in the practice of illicit
entrepreneurial activities may have
influenced their
their life was there any non-formal
punishment such as a loss of reputation
and you also have an early question from
aaron glasserman
um is there a difference between a local
official who corruptly profits on local
violation of socialist policy
and a local official who fosters fosters
entrepreneurship
um and there's a longer question but the
wrap-up question is
why isn't this just a story about local
corruption what does your research have
to say about rule of law in the prc
um and uh
um i don't have an audience questions
for gavin so maybe i'll take the chair's
prerogative
and ask you about the role of the china
travel service which comes up
in your desertion um and you're able to
discuss that length
um so i think that for many of us who
study or travel in china
we encounter the the china travel
service um in our own
going around and so i wondered if you
would talk more about the history of
that as a as a bureaucratic
as a private and bureaucratic
institution um and then
um when does the emergence of of private
or local
um travel agencies appear
shall we sure we'll start with peter
sorry i didn't know um
but thank you to the audience members
for these questions that
kind of overlap so i think i'll just
kind of take them together i think
um in terms of the students in that
there there's this really um
interesting evolution in the nature and
origin
of the students in these programs and
that
as the questions implied that in the
1980s
you really aren't talking about
primarily state-owned enterprise
and party managers of various
divisions and and and uh pieces
of the bureaucracy and state industry
many of whom are being assigned
foo to these programs for sometimes it's
just two weeks
for you know uh what we would probably
call an extended conference or
or something along those lines to
wholesale
one years or two years of re-education
of various kinds um
what's interesting though though is that
it does not there does not seem to be a
particular link
between who the students were in the
1980s and the nature of the content that
they're being
given and that from and i i do not have
as many
syllabi and curriculum such as i would
like um
but that a lot of the time what is being
taught
seems to be determined more by the
various
forms of partners and partnerships that
are structuring these programs
and so a good example is that um
the eg boos program be you know with
with bad it mostly in
in the the commanding role is largely
copying
mit's mba program from the beginning um
the shanghai municipal program which
where
the the students are very much being
assigned
from city enterprises but in our
mid-level career
career officials um is being in part run
by the chinese university of hong kong
by a person who was actually involved in
the china travel service before 1949 so
that's an interesting link which we can
talk about
kevin um and the beijing municipal
program
is being in part run by a swedish
management institute
so in the 80s at least there seems to be
this whole smorgasbord of
of different things going on that are uh
not necessarily correlated there um
for the mba students though isabella's
question assuming
we're really talking about the 90s i
don't have a lot of
interest a lot of firm data about 1991
when the program's open
to 1997 when the mit partnership starts
we have a ton of data
for after 1997 because in large part
mit strongly encourages fujian and ching
hwan to launch career development
centers
and those career development centers
keep track of
the students who they are and what they
go on to and
as uh denise will know from the paper um
part of what i think is just really
interesting is that
one of the things they kept track of is
what the students made before
in terms of money before they entered
the program and what they make after
the program and that they experience
huge pay rises
as the mba students graduate and largely
join
multinational corporations and foreign
joint ventures
in china so with the mba the foreign
structured mba programs
you see this interesting um
demographic of people who are aspiring
it seems or being scaffolded towards
careers very different careers in
multinationals and joint ventures
after these programs very different from
the 1980s
of people being pay food into into these
programs
am i up next sure okay great
um yeah so just to answer the question
so um
so i've interviewed dozens of former
government officials who were in charge
of prosecuting
uh illicit entrepreneurship and i've
interviewed uh many elicit
entrepreneurs who are engaged in these
underground activities
in these periods so through oral
histories i'm trying to explore more
uh of those dynamics i've interviewed i
i was really fortunate to interview for
example
who was the guy who started the iwo xiao
shipping
like the commodities market in iwo and
he's like maybe the first official
in china to really allow long-distance
trade
and commerce at the local level prior to
reform and opening up
um so so through those kind of
interviews i really get to explore
those dynamics a lot more um so is this
just a story
of corruption um i don't think so um
for one what's particular about my data
set right these are the cases of
entrepreneurs
who are prosecuted by the state so in
some way
like all i have is examples of failure
these are the guys who got caught
these are the guys who did not
successfully bribe the officials
these are the people that show up in the
historical record
any really successful illicit
entrepreneur is not part of history
written history right i mean they're
just not going to be in the documents
produced by the state
prosecuting these individuals and
furthermore
if corruption was the leading story we
wouldn't
necessarily expect to find strongly
patterned
activity um so we would expect that the
you know the bribery would be
um idiosyncratic to the individual to
the relationships and things like that
what i find in my data sets is
highly calculated and patterned um
forms of prosecution you see that
officials irrespective of who is being
prosecuted
prosecute some types of activities a lot
more than others
and that's so that's a really important
story that i'm trying to tell
and um in the in the list of i got
tinder so i got several questions um
a lot of them deal with you know what
what was the
nature of entrepreneurship how big was
it how long did it
uh how long did it carry on for so
in my dissertation project i look at the
the persistence of entrepreneurial
activity from
the very start of like the socialist
high tide
all the way to reform and opening up and
what i find is these practices are
ubiquitous
they're not contained to particular
regions of china and they persist
throughout the whole period so right in
the great leap forward there is tons
of illicit entrepreneurial activity
which i'm dealing with in the chapter
i'm writing right now
and and and someone asked me what you
know what am i doing different than the
existing accounts of entrepreneurship on
the master
there are existing accounts of
entrepreneurship in this period
but i would say a couple things one the
existing accounts really focus on the
socialist transformation period mostly
the really good stuff
robert cliver has some amazing work on
this a number of
other vigils as well but a lot of it
really stops at 1958.
um after that we do get some accounts
but they're really heavily biased
towards shanghai and wenzhou
like the experiences of those particular
places so they're very idiosyncratic and
they really don't tell us much
about um the you know the overall
picture
for china the relationship between
entrepreneurs uh
and the state so that's what i'm trying
to do differently i i'm building these
micro data sets to give us a sense
of like the full scale of this so in the
in the paper that i just presented i did
2 500 cases that were from two counties
why those two counties just simply
because
i was lucky enough to come across really
complete collections
of documents for those two counties but
in total i have more than 8
000 cases from across china which i'm
building into the data set but i have to
figure out how to deal with that data
because we have all different kind
it's incomplete so we have to figure out
how to deal with by potential biases
and things like that so i'm working on
that but i think we can also use the
type of data that i'm creating in novel
ways to really get at
other measures of how ubiquitous and
systemic uh
illicit entrepreneurship is for example
one thing i'm working on
right now is um i'm using
price differentials as a measure of the
perceived risk
of illicit entrepreneurial activity so
um
the best kind of way i can think of to
figure out how
systemic as i said again my data sets
case is a failure
so how how what size of all cases
possible cases do those represent that's
a really really tough question
to get at one way that i think i'm going
to try to get at it
is to use the reported price
differentials
in the price that um that elicit good
like ration coupons
cloth rations grain rations how much
they sold for and how much they were
purchased for
now theoretically at least this is
what's going through my mind right now
if we look at the differential in that
gap between the purchase and sale price
um entrepreneurs theoretically would be
calculating
in the potential risk of seizure i mean
these goods have like zero
transportation costs they're super
mutable it's almost like cash
so like the main thing that would be
going through entrepreneurs minds when
they're buying and selling in terms of
profit calculations
is what's how likely am i to get caught
and what
i have found so far in the analysis of
all these things is
that spread is tiny they were for
example
selling cloth rations for maybe um
five mile uh 50 cents a yard
and then they were buying them for 48
cents a yard that's a two you know it's
a tiny differential
which implies that their expectations of
getting caught
and getting all of those things seized
is relatively low and then there's other
costs too
and things but if we only say if we
attribute that spread only to risk
we can still get a sense that this
illicit economy and from that we can
then estimate backwards
maybe how many people are operating in
this space so so that's
that's the kind of gist of the thing i'm
trying to do provide a very quantitative
robust
uh rigorous way of getting at the
totality of entrepreneurial activity in
the economy and then of course
in addition to deep readings individual
case studies oral history
uh the stuff that is much more uh
robust in the current existing
literature
okay so great questions um
so for the first question about these
embattles of chinese
family state i think you um
you got a point about a very crucial
issue of
foundation i would i would argue a
fundamental issue about
the chinese conception of the state
which is right
at state family so according to the
confucian tradition
and especially according to the
traditional religion where the concept
of xiaokan and dhaka really came
about um feminist state were continuous
and
and deeply inter and inter and that so
first
you you started with the family as
foundation
right of your order and there's no
like big boundaries between what is
conceptually family and what is
conceptually
a d state like in aristotle's politics
so so so what happens after the
the mouse revolution was in fact i
argued in my
station i sort of returned to this
confucianized ideal of the family state
rather than what happened during the
great deport which i term it
as a state family that is to reduce
family to the dependents
or eventually eliminating family right
so the individuals who belong to this
biggest communist
society so so basically what happened
after the most revolution interestingly
is a return to become more of
confucianized norm
and that never happened in eastern
europe
and that's a very big reason why china
actually
survived the main uh the june force
right it's because of these fundamental
ideologies of xiaokong
that has tied in with china's old
traditions of more confusionalized and
valued state family
oh sorry family state and for the
question of um
one child policy in fact the most
interesting thing about one child policy
was that
is the continuation of these austerity
measures of
childbirth uh family planning which
started as
past and a part of the puzzle of this
austerity measures in the 60s that were
actually
put forth to deal with the fallout of
greatly forward
so what happened was that while all
other measures ceased to practice
because they were
extremely ideological um more
ideological mobile i i don't really
embed it
this one child policy this family
planning only become only
um were only strengthened and indeed
institutionalized to each extreme form
as one child policy
in post-modern china so so what happened
was that
there was the changing context and the
particular interpretations of
of this policy from a
anti-crisis measure so from this from
austerity measure
to a new discourse of state development
so basically it actually helps i mean so
so the basic justification was that
having less babies having less childhood
was a boom to the family welfare
because it reduced the cost and
eventually would lead to better economic
development that will benefit the
families
so it very much ties within this big
concept of xiaokong as modernization and
economic development
but it was not initially so windows
first
conceptualized in the 60s thank you
okay um thank you thank you denise um
for the for the excellent um question i
just um
i'll go relatively quickly i know we're
short on time um
i think related to the there basically
there's two agencies that
are sort of responsible for for tourism
uh for inbound foreign tourism in china
um during this period
one is the china international travel
service which hosts
you know you know sort of foreign
tourists the other is the overseas
chinese
um travel service which hosts um
basically
overseas chinese and many hong kong and
macau compatriots
of course not every tourist to china
comes through one of these agencies
there's
a variety of organizations in china
during this time that host
you know foreigners and take them to to
sightsee
one thing that i think i want to
underscore particularly regarding the
economic aspects of tourism
is that for every um tourists hosted by
the china international
travel service basically every sort of
european japanese
other western tourists there are
probably 10
tourists hosted by the overseas chinese
travel service
so economically the overseas chinese
travel service is always the more
important
agency even even though in a lot of the
sort of the travelers accounts we see
a lot more about the china international
travel service and particularly we see a
lot about
the sort of the frustrations about how
this agency is sort of prevents people
from
traveling to the places they want to to
go
but um all that being said um despite
that
having these sort of two sort of
overarching agencies their operations
are very very decentralized
and so they're you know each independ
each branch office
in a particular city is really sort of
staffed locally
and is sort of taking you know some some
sort of broad direction from the head
office but it's really like it's up to
themselves to
sort of like manage their finances and
manage their their program
and so that's why i think we see in the
cultural revolution and i think this
sort of is is how a segway to to i think
sarah chang has a question about the
periodization in the 1969 these the
head offices of these agencies get shut
down in beijing but the branches still
continue
so the branches are still operating
throughout the cultural revolution
and so in 1971 when there's this sort of
decision from top leadership that we
should
we can make some money from tourism um
the branches are really
pretty quickly you know able to sort of
to keep to
to step into gear and and host people
and um i mean i think part of that
decision in 1971
it's a very practical decision but i
think it's also you know related to the
cultural revolution and we've seen that
we've hosted a lot of people the chinese
government says we've hosted a lot of
people to come during the cultural
revolution and people are really drawn
to china during that period they want to
see
the revolution that's going on and so
this is a chance finally
that we can we you know we there's a
sort of realization
we don't have to pay the foot the bill
for all these people a lot of these
people are willing to come
and and pay their own way and this is a
chance for us to
sort of to make some some some money
from this from from hosting these people
so there's always a political element
and an economic element so but there's
this realization in 1971 that we can
we can earn some money even as we sort
of educate people
as to sort of what our vision of sort of
socialism is and what our vision of the
new china
is
thank you for that um so we are at time
um but i
i've been corresponding with a panelist
in the chat and
i think that consensus is we're okay
with going a few minutes over since
there's still a number of questions that
that didn't get addressed um so if those
of you who need to
to go in the participants are welcome to
go but i think as a chair i'll exercise
that prerogative and
and extend us for about 10 minutes since
we're not at ha no one is going to push
us out of the room
um and this is hananda to get us all
together in one space
um so perhaps we can do one more
question
um or one more comment from each
panelist as a way of wrapping up
um adam you have a rather long list of
five or six other questions that haven't
gotten
answered so if you want to choose one
one or two of those to address
and a final concluding remark um you uh
you're welcome to do that um yenja you
got a question in the
in the chat that i know you answered to
the individual but maybe you could
answer it
to the group mark levine
asks did you come across any instances
where sent down youth
youths wanted to stay in rural areas
contrary to the majority
what reasons would have considered
contributed to this desire ideological
familial etc
um uh gavin you i think you just
answered sarah's question
um verbally so if there's anything else
you want to add by way of conclusion um
please do so um and then peter i think
um i'm not seeing a final wrap-up
question for you
in the q a um so
maybe i can ask a final question for
your paper
um as you were showing all of those uh
screenshots of the
of the campuses and the people standing
around i was thinking about the
architecture of
of mit and the architecture of chinha so
they're
they're based on each other as a model
um and so i wondered about longer
institutional links
do you was this something that was um
either called upon in the building of
these schools
or um if it was if these longer
institutional links
were something that were invoked in the
commemorative materials that you were
using in your research
another way of asking this question is
in your
paper and the presentation you looked at
the hong kong alums
and these chinese american alums were
there any any chinese
alums of an earlier generation that were
part of this mba or the management
education
as you've started to research it
uh do you want me to go then in that
order okay sure
uh yeah so i think and there's a lot of
great questions i'm sorry i can't answer
them
all um i think i'll answer uh ron byrd's
question
and he asks from an archival concern
what has been the fate of these
documents you discovered on your
research is there a common fate
a prc archival documents to be
discovered
in private hands um great question so
um there's this whole you know kind of
school of literature um
that is sometimes referred to as
cynological garbology
um although i don't really like that
term uh but it was really you know
uh i think michael schoenhall's was
really one of the kind of leaders
in this field and beginning in the 1990s
he started going around to these flea
markets just as i've done
and buying up a lot of former government
archives that had slipped into private
circulation
so during the 1980s in china there was
this
massive purge of archives as the various
government institutions were being
merged
and at the time uh there were paper
shortages in china
so instead of just burning the documents
or scrapping them
the archivists were instructed to turn
over these documents to paper pulpers
who would theoretically recycle them but
then somewhere between the archivist and
the paper pulper someone decides to like
sell them into private
circulation so there are enormous
quantities
of local government archival materials
still in private circulation today and
you see many
scholars and institutions now
particularly because of the recent
archival closures in china
in the past few years there's been a lot
of people that have been working to
um recollect these documents and then
assemble
private and institutional archives so
yenjia is a prime example
uh the archive he worked with uh it was
at fuden started by john le tian it's a
really massive collection
uh of all different kinds of uh really
interesting materials that he
acquired from local villages in the
jejung
area and and uh johnson area
um but then there's scholars in europe
that are doing the same thing uh michael
schoenhall's daniel lees
in particular are leading this stanford
university
at the hoover and the hoover institute
are trying to actively
procure these materials so there is a
collective effort among
uh certain persuasion of historians
today
to go and reconstitute
uh these local archives in order you
know that we can continue to promote
future historical research in the face
of uh shrinking archival access but as
the engine mentions there's ethical
concerns with this how do we do this
appropriately how do we protect
our the source of our sources how do we
protect
the privacy of the individuals mentioned
in the sources
and i think for all of these concerns
personally i i think we should adopt the
practice of like anthropologists
and journalists and you know just go for
full anonymity and like we need to
rethink
how as historians we engage in citation
practices how we make these materials
available to other people
but but for example i myself am trying
to fully digitize my collection
and then make it available uh to the
academic community after some kind of
privatization
of the materials to protect the
anonymity of the people mentioned
uh but i think this is a really
important effort and i hope other
historians will
join in and make it possible to continue
preserving these documents
um just few words and in addition to
your items i
told you agree with you about the um
astonishing challenges actually we are
i mean with my collaborators in in china
we're also digitizing
the latter collections and trying to
make it into a
uh textual form where we can actually
use textual analysis
or other more modernist implements uh
even
uh uh magnation learning to study the
rhetoric and
um and the changing uh and the networks
there
so there are a lot of things going on i
think we can have
um some exchanges later on the
latest development so so basically i
think grassroots source will be
increasingly important for our research
and the there are a lot of
things on the table for us to to think
about
uh ranging from private protection to
the kind of methodological challenges
of using them so um for mass question
about
who are uh the those staying behind
on um use uh sundown use actually there
are
a number of them but they were among the
very distinctive minority
and and eventually they were all more
urbanized i think as far as i know
but locally so basically they they moved
to
the local counties or local cities where
then
rather than going back to like big
cities like shanghaine or beijing where
they were originally from and the big
reason for them to settle locally
and i happened to discuss about this in
a wild medicine chapters
about family reunion was that they
already started their families
and in in the 70s they already started
dating
and that was a big issue because once
you started that
you basically embedded locally and it's
extremely difficult to
ex execute that's what they use and
eventually you have to
like forcefully lay down your own plan
and
sort more about your children and
eventually what what happened was that
you are bounding there so so that's what
happened to you to most um
youth who eventually settle down locally
and become part of the local society
um i think that's all i can offer uh and
and and and thank you for the question
gavin do you have any final uh questions
or comments you'd like to
say is to wrap up um i i think one thing
i'd like to talk about is that you
mentioned
um the sort of the geographic aspect
of of my research and i'd like to just
talk about that and going forward is
that you know here
i think one sort of like um one thing we
see going throughout this is that
you know sort of tourism is is dependent
on sort of mobility and immobility
and in this case in sort of my research
we see sort of the mobility of people
coming from hong kong
or coming from other overseas to to to
visit an immobile sort of population in
china and during the 1970s
but of course now i mean tourism is in
china is very very different
you know the people studying tourism and
the students that i met
when i was in in china who are studying
tourism are not studying
you know inbound foreign tourism they're
starting they're studying either
outbound
tourism or they're studying domestic
tourism and so
as in my research i see tourists coming
and
mainly centered on guangdong shanghai
hangzhou and beijing
and now we see and that sort of shifts
in the 80s to a sort of a much
sort of broader sort of array of
destinations are open to people
and part of that is by state decree
there's a certain certain destinations
that are open to people now
like many many more um but like tourism
today
is is not about bringing foreign so much
about bringing foreign currency from
outside
to sort of guangdong and coastal china
it's about taking
the money and the mobility of people in
guangdong and people in shanghai and
beijing and coastal urban areas
and like having them shift some of that
income to help develop sort of the
hinterland whether it's
it's tibet it's cuisho it's places like
that so i think like
tourism sort of always sort of functions
with that that tension
of the sort of mobility of one
population and the immobility of another
but it's a way of trying to sort of
shift sort of the flow of currency
of some sort from one place to another
thank you
peter last word
um you asked about the the the
architecture and the pairing between
mit and chiang juan as um
correctly you know diagnosed there that
it was very much evoked in this
um kind of superficial way as this
logical pairing
makes a lot of historical sense because
of our previous roots and
it's in some sense almost a healing you
know of reestablishing these ties
and these connections um but as you
sharply picked up on
um you know part of my interest in and
entry into this was through the hong
kong
elite connection and that people of the
foreign tycoons that i that i pictured
there
two of them either their father or
grandfather had gone to qinghua
as boxer indemnity students and then on
to mit
um and that um
as very savvy operators who would
understand
um that education is training
and that um the kind of social capital
you can buy
through donations to institutions their
agenda i think is really
interesting here at a more critical and
and um
uh you know political reading of what
they're doing rather than just the
celebratory accounts
of you know multi-generational
educational patronage
um that instead you know kind of trying
to
steer educational systems in the
mainland
toward what they think would be useful
in the future and most especially to
themselves
um
this is somewhat uh some roundabout way
of saying that
part of my interest here i think is is
uh i find
mit's agenda absolutely baffling i
really don't i find it
fascinating that they pursued this in
the way that they did largely on pretty
vague ideas of what they were going to
get out of it in terms of
prestige you know um uh
but interestingly i think that the hong
kong elite donors agendas they i get
deeply anti-communist uh and kind of
very immersed in this kind of high
transnational politics
of elite higher education and what it
can do
if that answers your question
thank you um so again i i want to wrap
up and um thank all of the panelists
uh to yenja for organizing to stephanie
kim and the yale council of asian east
asian studies for for hosting us today